♪ ♪
>> Sean: SOME HOUSE
REPUBLICANS DEMANDING THEY
INVESTIGATE THE ABUSES OF POWER
UNDER OBAMA.
BY THE WAY, WHAT DID THEY KNOW
AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT?
WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT MEETING IN
EARLY JANUARY IN THE OVAL OFFICE
OVAL OFFICE.
MEMORIALIZED ON TRUMP’S
INAUGURATION DAY.
OH, MUCH LATER.
WE REVEALED IT LAST NIGHT.
THEY WERE READY TO CLOSE OUT THE
INVESTIGATION.
PLEASE KEEP THIS OPEN.
HE OBLIGED, DESPITE NO GOOD
FAITH OR FACTUAL BASIS TO DO SO.
AND AS ANTHONY McCARTHY POINTS
OUT, HE WAS AN OBSTACLE IN THE
LARGER TRUMP RUSSIA HOPES.
THAT’S ABOUT IT GOT.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE, FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN, TREY
GOWDY.
EVERYTHING WE SAID UNREPORTED IS
TRUE.
WHEN I READ THAT LETTER LAST --
WHAT IS OUR GOAL HERE?
IS OUR GOAL TO GET AN ADMISSION?
IS OUR GOAL TO FORCE SOMEBODY TO
LIE AND GET THEM IN A LIE?
IS OUR GOAL TO PROSECUTE.
IT IS OUR GOAL TO GET THEM
FIRED?
SHOULD THAT EVER BE A QUESTION
THAT ANY FBI ASKS?
>> THAT SOMETHING NOT CHRIS WRAY
IS GOING TO HAVE TO ASK FOR.
HOW MUCH HAS THE FBI CHANGED?
THE FBI IS NOT IN CHARGE OF
HIRING NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
THE FBI IS NOT IN CHARGE OF --
IT’S NOT THEIR JOB TO SEE WHAT
THEY CAN GET.
GET A GAGGLE OF LIBERALS WHEN HE
WAS DOING THAT.
THAT IS NOT THE FBI.
TRY TO GET SOMEBODY FIRED.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO CREATE
CRIME.
BUT PETER IS THE ANTITHESIS OF
FINALITY, BRAVERY, AND
INTEGRITY.
YOU AND I SHOULDN’T BE
SURPRISED.
THE SAME GUY WHO HAS THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION’S IS WHO
ULTIMATELY WANTED TO GET TRUMP.
>> I’M WATCHING THE PROSECUTOR,
MY SOURCES ARE CONFIRMING TO ME.
THEY ARE THE ONES INSISTED THIS
BE RELEASED.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY URGENCY FROM
DIRECTOR WRAY.
I WOULD LIKE HIM NOT ONLY TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS, BUT
FURTHERMORE, I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO AND
WHEN HE IS GOING TO DO IT.
DOES HE HAVE A COMMITMENT?
HE SHOWS NO URGENCY.
TO CLEAN UP THE PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE
WORLD.
HE LOOKS TO ME COME ON THE
OUTSIDE, LIKE A CONSTITUTION AND
THAT CAN STARTING TO ME.
>> IT SHOULDN’T TAKE A LETTER TO
GET THESE QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
BILL BARR IS HIS BOSS.
WHICH IS CONTROLLED BY
REPUBLICANS.
I WANT TO KNOW, IS THIS STILL
THE FBI?
DOES THE FBI STILL WANT TO SET
THEM UP?
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
THAT WOULD BE MY QUESTION.
HE WASN’T AROUND, BUT HE HAS
BEEN THERE TWO YEARS.
WE CAN ALL HAVE CONFIDENCE AND,
THAT IS NOT WHAT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO TRUST THEM.
HE WAS RIGHT.
IT’S KIND OF MADE SENSE WHEN HE
SAID THAT ABOUT DIRTY COPS.
LET ME GO TO ANOTHER TOPIC.
I WAS SKEPTICAL OF GOVERNOR COMP
AND GEORGE’S GEORGE’S MEASURES.
I LIKE THE CREATIVITY.
AS GOVERNOR HUCKABEE WAS SAYING,
EVERYBODY IN MICHIGAN NEEDS TO
BE TICKED OFF.
SHE DID A HORRIBLE JOB.
SHE HAS ACCUSED -- I GUESS SHE’S
AUDITIONING.
WHEN YOU CAN’T PLANT SEEDS AND
YOU CAN’T CUT YOUR LAWN, THESE
ARE RIDICULOUS MEASURES.
DENYING THEIR RIGHTS.
I UNDERSTAND THEIR ANGER.
I DID NOT LIKE THE GUYS -- I
WANT PEOPLE TO BE HEARD FOR THE
BETTER PART OF IT.
BUT, MY QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU
DO WITH THESE WHEN THEY ARE
SCREWING UP SO BADLY?
>> WELL, WE HAVE A RICH HISTORY
OF CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE.
AND THE PEOPLE NEED TO SAY --
THEY ARE ASKING US TO DO THESE
THINGS.
WHAT IS THE RATIONAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN WHAT YOU ARE MAKING US
DEAL, AND THE OUTCOME YOU HOPE
TO ACHIEVE.
AND IF LEADERS CAN’T CONVINCE US
OF THAT, THEN MAYBE WE NEED TO